and i don't know why
well happy glorious wednesday to you
first a little housekeeping words cat
has never uttered in her life
if you watched our show last night you
know that one of our producers gene
nelson was stuck in the elevator for
hours even as we taped the show
well the fire department actually freed
gene and he was taken to a local
hospital where they examined his knee
which was apparently strained when the
elevator plunged temporarily
we're happy he's well though and we wish
him luck in his future career endeavors
yeah yes we fired him he missed a show
and that's how it goes
i'm running a tv show here not a friggin
ihop
i just wish i had a chance to meet him
first
so speaking of trapped should we talk
about taylor lorenz you probably don't
know her but whatever she was a former
dishonest reporter for the new york
times as if that narrows things down who
made her living creeping around the web
trying to find people to cancel for
saying inappropriate stuff she's a real
jerk she then became a dishonest
reporter for the washington post to do
the same thing it's the perk of being a
lefty screwing up only gets you a better
job somewhere else but in between being
a slimy slug she went on msnbc to talk
about how she was a victim of online
mobbery
can you draw a picture of what it is
like when a surge of harassment hits
it's completely overwhelming it's
horrifying and it's not just me either
you know they immediately dox you and go
after your family members they try and
look up everyone who's ever you know
been associated with you
you feel like any little piece of
information
that gets out on you will be used by the
worst people on the internet to destroy
your life
and it's
so isolating
and terrifying
it's horrifying
i'm so sorry
it's overwhelming it's really hard it
really is
there's nothing funny about attempting
to make people's lives unbearable
through online mobbery
well
unless it happens to someone who makes
their living making people's lives
unbearable through online mobbery then
it's funnier than tyrus trying on
clothes at lululemon
one time i know
see lorenz was a breathless online cop
who once eavesdropped on an online
discussion and falsely accused the tech
executive of using a slur
after she was caught lorenz bravely
locked her account meanwhile like an
evil santa claus she kept a blog of
names of people who said things she
deemed problematic she was her own
canceled culture machine a goon a thug a
bully and when it suited her a victim
but now just weeks after she claimed to
have severe ptsd severe ptsd over being
doxxed which she claims was due to her
gender she's back to her old tricks
contacting friends and family of the
woman behind the popular libs of tick
tock twitter account
lorenz claims the woman's posts were
anti-gay and inciting outrage even
though the users posted the content
themselves
true the account shows unedited already
public videos of ranty lefties in all
their green haired
glory but lorenz was so obsessed she
even went after someone with a similar
name which is like me making drug jokes
about pat timf
the washington post ran her piece
complete with the tick tock ladies name
and a link to the listing of her
professional real estate license with
her address
that's doxing by definition
the victim called in to tucker last
night let's play that how has this
affected your life this jeff bezos piece
i have to make
some travel plans you know really fast
but i'm now in a location where i don't
think anyone would find me not in any of
the locations that they remember runs
bleak
so after claiming
she was targeted
taylor lorenz resumes targeting people
she demonizes
hiding behind the lie that she's
fighting bigotry when in fact she just
gets off on it and the washington post
defends her the paper denies posting
private info of lorenz's target but they
did
sure they eventually deleted the link
but what you post online lasts forever
just like those cheesecake photos of
stuart varney
he's actually eating cheesecake in them
now
in the good old days before social media
lorenz's behavior would have cost her a
job it wouldn't even be a job actually
she's doing the opposite of speaking
truth to power instead using her power
position to target plebes that takes a
lot of balls right i put it right up
there with our great reporters covering
the war on the ground in ukraine
now you've heard the phrase live by the
sword die by the sword well i came up
with it after living with my college
roommate steve sword
he was a wild man nearly killed me
but when you live by the mob you will be
crushed by the mob what goes around
eventually comes around
she's like the mentally ill guy who
attacks an old woman on the street and
when the cops show up to physically take
him down he's screaming police brutality
how can she play the victim imagine
working with someone like that
i can't take the bullying anymore
everyone is so mean to me and i just
can't handle the disrespect and how
hurtful they are okay i'm a victim all
right i am
the victim
can i go home yet three more hours shut
up jerry
as for lorenz she's worked at big name
powerful media companies she's got power
and clout she can ruin you just by
accusing you of saying something and
then amplifying it
even if she's 100 wrong she'll never
apologize or just collateral damage
she's a grown woman with a massive media
company behind her outing the private
lives of people maybe that's why she's
miserable it's not about being targeted
at all it's about how she targets others
lorenz enjoyed the hunt and the scalping
that comes with cancel culture until it
came for her
and still she can't stop she's just one
example of someone who makes a living
depriving others of making a living she
decries the mob unless she's leading it
so if anyone would like to protest in
front of her house
here's the address it's number one
hypocrite ave jerkville usa apartment
666.
let's welcome
he's written more scripts than michael
jackson's doctor tv writer and producer
problem
his preferred pronouns are daddy and
master
editor chief of outspoken middle east
and contributing editor of the or at the
ex spectator chadwick moore
she's like a taxidermy bunny
looks cute on the outside but completely
dead in the inside butts contributor
and he's so strong he can go up niagara
falls in a barrel my massive sidekick in
the nwa world television champion tyrus
greg
yes
guy town
again is it guy town yeah skytown you
know what that means
shooting hoops with your buddies and
telling jokes then you build a shed for
some reason wearing suits and shades and
talking to cool babes but it's fun if
you prefer dudes we don't judge
part two of guy town rob
[Laughter]
i missed part one oh man you know what
you gotta go back to understand part two
wait you gotta see the first one that
would mean i'd have to watch the show
yeah it'll it'll be you know what it's
like godfather oh okay you know like
godfather two you watch it it's okay on
its own but godfather one adds to god
father to you i got you waiting that's
exactly like that i got you exactly um
you need to sew that sweater up cat oh i
get it yeah you know um if canceling is
your sport then you got to live by the
rules of the game right isn't that what
what yeah i mean it's kind of weird
because to me like first of all i as you
know i'm very hip with the kids so i'm
on the tick tock right and i follow the
tick tock uh application bone
application yes yes so that's what we
call it uh and i've actually enjoyed
this one this one's great but it's like
i mean and i love the woman who does it
she's like super talented the liberal so
the woman who does this
yeah but the the the it's not i mean
it's not like that hard i mean it
doesn't really repost stuff right right
it's very little that she does which so
it's kind of strange that there's that
much rage yes from because she chose
liberal
rage to expose it and that caused taylor
lorenz to go after her all it does is
amplify yes voices that are already
there i mean what the left is always
saying is like we just want to be heard
yeah we want our voices heard so and
then when they're heard they go
right exactly uh the the doxing and all
this stuff i mean i i get it and i i
said the thing before because i do i do
sympathize with this woman because not
not this woman but the woman who does
the libs of tick tock right um but you
know we
we did used to send everybody a giant
book
every year
that had everyone's address in it that's
true it was i believe it was called it's
called the phone book right i used to
sit on one when i drove um yeah that's
right you probably did
and you got and they get your hair cut
yes um
and so that some of this stuff seems
sometimes it's always like everyone's
crying all the time and saying they've
been violated and all that stuff it's
like i think everybody needs to sort of
take a little deep breath all right all
right i'm not trying to be unsympathetic
but i'm a little bit unstep at that you
make a great psychiatrist especially
what you're wearing yeah yeah we could
talk about that in our next session i
want to tell you about a dream i had
it'll be five hundred dollars and i'll
listen to anything you've got that's the
dream oh really paying you 500
wow
i'm a cash dom chadwick
i look at this and i have i feel kind of
i feel like the washington post has the
responsibility to assess the mental
health of taylor lorenz when somebody
goes and claims victimhood from being
doxxed and then goes and doxes
something's off i would agree with you
if she weren't every liberal i know
there's absolutely no diversity in the
party of diversity every single time if
you if you dare to you know they spend
their lives uh spewing the most hateful
things calling other people the most
hateful things uh weaponizing the
nuclear arsenal of the mainstream media
to dox harass destroy lives the minute
they get an iota of that in return it's
i will kill myself yes if you keep going
with this you know i am the victim here
it's it's the cry bully is what this
this term was uh invented for but it she
takes it a step further than just a cry
bullying this creature is something else
but she's also it's it's ridiculous in
the clips that we saw it's it's comedy
it it it is it is it it's that she it's
the shield like oh i was suicidal and
there were everybody that and then she
locks herself outside out so that way no
one come after me and then when
everything comes out she's back at it
right well
listen as an actor and a wrestler i have
experienced some bad acting in my day i
have seen
some stuff
and uh if you watch that scene back
there is a great spot where she forgot
her line
yes and her interviewer tried to help
her yes when she leaned because she was
already leaning forward right and she
was like and traumatic yeah and then she
said it was horrible yeah and then she
got frazzled because she forgot her
thing and did the fake cry please i need
a minute and everybody but everyone was
leaning forward because she had
something else going watch it back again
watch it right as a director or watch it
as like when you like to watch your
movies and you were super critical of
bad acting yeah watch it again they this
was it couldn't be any more planned on
how many i guess they didn't have time
for any more takes but
this was planned uh you know she's she's
literally trying to show how hurt she is
and it's completely plus why was uh why
was justin bieber there yeah yeah i
don't understand that well it was all
they were all there to do something yeah
okay it's just this is what happens when
people get together with plots and stuff
it's like jesse small a it's like when
they get together and someone's not with
the script and this was the same thing i
think the other one was they were
supposed to be the other individual was
there for support we probably should
have some line or something that was
supposed to be contributed but she got
caught up in the moment and i'm sure
when they were sitting talking about
she's like i just went with it and then
the crime like oh it was so great we got
our message yes and yeah no it's funny
which she has severe ptsd which i think
really puts joey jones in this place
anyone within 12 miles of ukraine right
yeah exactly exactly so casual or
chicago she actually tweeted again this
was at 12 45 pm um she can't about the
amount of insane stuff that's happened
over the past 24 hours has been
unbelievable it's eye-opening to see how
sophisticated and vicious these
coordinated attacks have become i'm
grateful to work at a company that's
taking these issues seriously so she is
talking about how she's protected by a
huge company right while talking about
these coordinated attacks she has more
power than anybody yeah she's using eye
opening wrong because like
what are you presenting here yeah that
is not the one thing that you do right
which is go after people because
obviously it's not the first time she's
done this no go after people cancel them
and then cry when people get upset about
it yes and the interview was so fake but
let's say it was true she's sitting
there she's like i have such not just
ptsd but he said severe ptsd certainly
one of the worst cases they've ever seen
yeah
uh just you know i i still want to do
anything it was like reading this stuff
it's like okay well then might i
recommend another activity yes cause you
don't just sit there i mean i see
horrible things about me on the internet
but that's only when i'm looking and i'm
there's people telling me to kill myself
that i don't even know about i apologize
for that every time he did apologize
yeah just like to say gregory it's just
a combination of medications and alcohol
i've gotten you greg i i disagree with
you man she doesn't have power that
tweet was a threat
to the i'm so thankful i have a company
vacuuming because if you have a company
backing you you don't have to bring it
up that's such a good point that was a
threat yes oh god you're so perceptive
thank you that's a god i wish i thought
of that but instead he did
he's after my job
i told you
he is after your job but you're spread
pretty thin let's be honest yeah it's
got a lot going on all right up next
does it make liberals nervous when
viewers reject their streaming service
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else